[Música]
morir es triste pero más triste todavía
es no vivir
hace un par de días vi una película que
me emocionó profundamente klaus
les confieso que la vi solo para poder
llorar a gusto
no se las voy a expoliar ahora pero
cuenta la historia de un joven saxo bien
que a pesar de su cáncer terminal
decidió aprovechar los últimos meses de
su vida con mucha intensidad y escribió
esta hermosa canción de klaus
él decida
no tienen que descubrir que están
muriendo para empezar a vivir y su
canción llegó a ocupar el primer lugar
en itunes con más de 200 millones de
descargas y reproducciones
y me recordó la frase del escritor
británico oscar wine
que es conocido por su sarcasmo social
decía este escritor británico vivir es
la cosa más rara del mundo porque la
mayoría de las personas tan solo existen
zach no se conformó con existir el lucho
para vivir y por eso amo lloro se
emocionó tomó decisiones y asumió los
riesgos porque eso es la vida ser
protagonistas y no solamente
espectadores el poeta latino juvenal en
el siglo 100 antes de cristo en la
sátira décima a como una frase que hasta
el día de hoy nosotros la seguimos
usando 'pan y circo' y describe la
práctica del gobierno para distraer la
atención del público y mantenerlo
entretenido y los romanos acudían en
masa al circo por el puro placer de
mirar
sin tener ninguna responsabilidad el
espectáculo era para ellos como una
droga que los adormecía y así poco a
poco los romanos que hicieron grandes
proezas y conquistas
quedaron inmortalizadas por ejemplo en
la columna de trajano en el arco de tu
nuevo distrito ya gusto de constantí o
poco a poco estos romanos que fueron
conquistadores fueron víctimas de la
corrupción víctimas de la decadencia
moral ellos dejaron de ser los
protagonistas de la historia para ser
simplemente espectadores quisiera
desarrollar este punto que para mí es
decisivo parafraseando a shakespeare
diría
espectador o protagonista esa es la
cuestión nosotros decidimos cuál es
nuestro rol en la historia
neil bowdler médico gerontólogo
psiquiatra y ganador de un premio
pulitzer opinaba que en la vida hay tres
tipos de personas las que hacen que las
cosas ocurren
las que ven cómo ocurren las cosas y las
que se preguntan qué ocurrió los
protagonistas pertenecen al primer grupo
son aquellos que se involucran en
primera persona ponen manos a la obra no
se quedan inertes con los brazos
cruzados mirando cómo va la historia
ellos quieren imprimirla en un sentido y
una dirección
en el segundo grupo están los
espectadores gente pasiva acomodada
embriagada por el placer de mirar ellos
están ahí para ver nuevo para actuar y
por último los despistados los que
llegan siempre tarde y preguntan qué fue
lo que ocurrió
hoy en día miles de personas
millones tal vez parece que nos
conformamos con ver cómo ocurren las
cosas nos quedamos como espectadores de
la historia observando la pero sin que
formemos parte de ella
la industria del entretenimiento como la
cultura gamer el negocio lucrativo de
los deportes electrónicos las series y
las películas de las diversas
plataformas de streaming los
espectáculos los shows los los programas
de la actualidad han secuestrado nuestra
atención son como el pan y circo de la
antigua roma y acudimos seducidos a la
pantalla global que es el título de uno
de los libros de gilles lipovetsky
filósofo y sociólogo francés y de jean
serroy profesor de universidad y doctor
en letras si todas sus palabras vídeo
pantalla pantalla miniaturizada pantalla
gráfica pantalla nómada pantalla táctil
el nuevo siglo es el ciclo de la
pantalla omnipresente y multiforme
planetaria y multi mediática y
efectivamente las pantallas hoy en día
se han vuelto omnipresentes tanto en los
lugares públicos gastamos muchas horas
de nuestro día mirando una pantalla por
motivos de trabajo por motivos de
estudio por motivos incluso también de
simple curiosidad o entretenimiento las
pantallas forman parte de nuestra vida
pero no toda nuestra vida tiene que ser
parte de las pantallas
yo considero que es urgente rescatar al
protagonista
en el cuento clásico de aladino el genio
se encontraba atrapado en una lámpara
maravillosa la lámpara podía hacer todo
lo maravillosa que nosotros queramos
pero el genio estaba atrapado
hay miles de genios que están atrapados
no en una lámpara sino en una pantalla
y qué decir de la bella durmiente' una
joven increíble mente hermosa así como
las que yo tengo delante ahora
pero estaba dormida
cuántas jóvenes hoy en día tan
talentosas y de ellas están adormecidas
por el efecto seductor de una pantalla
y los hermanos hans y gretel que
mientras sigan por el bosque fueron
atraídos por aquella casa de caramelo y
de chocolate
pero fueron engañados y terminaron
enjaulados cuantos niños hoy en día
sin darse cuenta sucumben ante la
fascinación de una pantalla colorida
y permítanme la expresión terminan en
pantalla 2 sin poder despegarse de un
ipad o de un celular que podemos hacer
nosotros me preguntó para rescatar a
tantos genios para despertar a tantas
jóvenes para libertar a tantos niños y
niñas que de alguna manera cayeron en el
hechizo de la tecnología hipnotizados no
por una bola de cristal sino por una
pantalla nosotros necesitamos la
intuición y la destreza de aladino
necesitamos nosotros el espíritu
aventurero y la valentía del príncipe
que se atrevió a despertar a la bella
durmiente' necesitamos por último
trabajar en equipo como lo hicieron los
dos hermanos más ingleses para superar
las dificultades que encontraron en su
camino qué fácil es desaparecer detrás
de una pantalla bajo un perfil falso que
nosotros creamos y así huimos de nuestra
responsabilidad y dejamos que otros
decidan por nosotros dejamos que otros
ocupen el lugar que nos corresponde en
la historia
pero seamos realistas
no podemos privar nos de los grandes
beneficios que la tecnología nos ofrece
no podemos dejar de lado las pantallas
porque ya forman parte de nuestra vida
seguiremos siendo es verdad espectadores
pero si afinamos nuestra mirada crítica'
y la hacemos una mirada receptora y
transformadora una mirada que es capaz
de actuar y de transformar de cambiar la
realidad entonces vamos a asumir nuestro
rol de protagonistas
les estoy hablando de una mirada que sea
capaz de incendiar la realidad porque
antes nos ha quemado por dentro y esa
mirada activa y dinámica que es como una
chispa ayudará al espectador a tomar
conciencia de su papel dentro de la
historia sin su valiosa participación
sin nuestra participación la trama de la
historia quedaría incompleta recuerden
la historia de harry potter harry potter
tuvo que asumir asumir su rol de
protagonista junto con sus inseparables
amigos ron y hermione para poder liberar
a la escuela de hogwarts recordemos
también a frodo frodo le costó llevar el
anillo en la historia del señor de los
anillos' escrita por tolkien para poder
liberar a la tierra media a la tierra de
los hombres cifrado hubiera huido
de su responsabilidad
todo habría desaparecido en este momento
alguien podría pensar hacer la historia
y qué pasa si me equivoco
si queriendo asumir el rol de
protagonista cometo errores y es verdad
probablemente nos vamos a equivocar y
vamos a cometer muchos errores pero eso
no es muy importante
thomas alva edison que descubrió la
bombilla de luz dijo
descubrir 999 maneras de cómo no hacer
una bombilla de luz y él también tiene
esta otra frase que dice no fracase no
fracase una experiencia nunca es un
fracaso pues siempre viene a demostrar a
alguien
alguien podrá decir el espectador nunca
se equivoca y tiene toda la razón porque
nunca hace nada y ese ese es su peor
error
al inicio de nuestra plática comenzamos
diciendo morir no es lo triste lo triste
es no vivir vivir es una aventura
apasionante como para quedarnos sentados
como espectadores vale la pena el riesgo
de vivirla en primera persona es
demasiado emocionante para dejar que
otros la vivan por nosotros miremos las
pantallas si estudiemos le damos
investiguemos pero sobre todo sobre todo
miremos la realidad muchas veces la
realidad que nosotros admiramos en las
pantallas la tenemos delante de nuestros
ojos gritando nos
adele esta famosa cantante británica en
su gira que hizo por italia en el año
2016 en el concierto que ofreció no en
la ciudad de verona se permitió decirle
a una de sus fans
puedes dejar de filmar me estoy
realmente aquí en vivo disfruta me en la
realidad y no a través de una cámara
nosotros disfrutemos de la realidad en
vivo y en directo y no solo a través de
una pantalla yo les invito a y con esto
ya voy terminando les invito para que
vivamos como protagonistas de la
historia el streaming y la alta
definición no puede sustituir la vida
real tomar tu vida en tus manos no
solamente una pantalla
vive y no solamente ve
por favor no nos privemos a los demás de
tantos talentos de toda esa riqueza
interior que llevamos dentro en nuestro
corazón no nos quedemos atrapados en una
pantalla porque muchos están necesitando
de nuestra ayuda usa la pantalla no solo
mira en ella sino a través de ella
y termino con esta poesía del poeta
español gustavo adolfo bécquer
del salón en el ángulo oscuro
de su dueña tal vez olvidada silenciosa
y cubierta de polvo veías el arpa
cuanta nota dormía en sus cuerdas como
el pájaro duerme en las ramas esperando
la mano de nieve que sabe arrancar las
y pensé
cuántas veces el genio así duerme en el
fondo del alma y una voz como la sal o
espera que le diga levántate y anda
queridos jóvenes querido público es hora
de despertar al genio que hay dentro de
nosotros para ser los protagonistas de
la historia muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]